[Musique]
la vie c'est tout con est astucieux
bellemène et la ligue 1 le plus vite à
jouer il le vouloir un ami
à la toujours comment fais-tu la baïse
et ça va pas bien quoi
et encore bien beau aujourd'hui t'as pas
de cravate
non non parce que nous sommes entre amis
je n'ai pas mis de cravate enfin malgré
tout je me lavais salle et dit bonjour
qui tous bonjour titou thermique et non
bâti tout va bien est ce qu'on va faire
tu vas voir je vais te montrer dit tout
comment avec une simple règle en
plastique on peut arriver à attraper les
bouts de papiers
ils sont là devant toi on peut série ça
on peut faire ça et je vais utiliser ton
bonnet si tu le veux bien pour frotter
assez fort la règle que j'ai devant moi
un navire sont bonnes et hop tu auras
regarde regarde regarde titou regardons
voir à ses formidables samira là on va
essayer une deuxième fois
attention quand tu as sont bonnes et je
me suis saignée aux quatre veines oui je
sais pas abîmer son badge et voilà au
fabrice est formidable hamida ben là les
gens mot-à-mot à léon jouhaux mot-à-mot
règle moi j'aime bien le mot amour aller
le moteur à bord mon panier est là avec
toutes les cartes dont nous avons besoin
et vous savez que ces cartes
représentent
soit des animaux soit des objets soient
des choses etc et en une syllabe en
général une seule syllabe et ensuite
nous devons utiliser ses syllabes pour
former d'autres mots est-ce que vous
êtes prêts on est alors en disant tu
dire sereine carton oui oui bien entendu
je vais tirer cinq cartons la hat en
charge 35 alors accompagné 3,4 et puis
25e savary baume qui a trouvé
oui oui j'ai travaillé à lyon alors
qu'est ce que c'est ça je tu n'en ce nom
et c'est une ans non c'est une ans
souhaite une ans ça qu'est ce que c'est
ça tout quand sa wind a c'est une vraie
oui et ça c'est une coupe ou un verre
emballages
ça c'est un rêve mais c'est une vis ça
c'est la vis oui il était alors ça c'est
1 passe et 1 2
le chiffre 2 fait le chiffre est bon il
va essayer de travailler un peu qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec ça je peux
faire avec ça pas une idée n'est pas là
mais je crois que pour attirer d'autres
alors retiré des autres qu'est ce que tu
veux attirer d'autres
qu'est ce que tu penses de ça c'est une
selle oui alors là haut ça y est on peut
faire vaisselle attends attends rester
là je suis dit qu'est ce qui vous est ce
que tu vois qu'on peut faire vaisselle
et b à ba non peut pas fermer on peut
pas faire baisser vient de sortir une
porte
oui c'est une porte mais c'est pas
merveilleux la wii continue je continue
je ça c'est une note ses amis on
attendait on avance vers deux vit seule
porte me bats je crois que j'ai trouvé
oui les trouver de quoi de la soupe de
la troupe vous savez ce n'est là tout
vienne a tout du vermicelle de la troupe
attendez attendez attendez quelque chose
dans ce qu'il dit 20 bougez pas béni oui
oui
elle abat ce qu'on voit là un mot at
their me seul permis tel bord sept
membres qu'ils aient trouvé les traces
passe assez bien
jouer alors bravo vermicelles javel
écrit ça ne fait que trois syllabes
d'abbas est pas si mal tu as fais même
plus d'ailleurs vermicelles le son fait
4 alors vers mi celle un somme n'est
d'accord un vermicelles des vermicelles
est détournée l'éprouver vernis et ça
c'est bon ça ckac à trouver vu qu'andy
et moi je te félicite a été meilleur
parce qu'on était en panne un
département maintenance de tous ces
décors du concret n'a pas été bon et moi
je te le dis toi non plus d'ailleurs
pouces me suis tu as pas trouvé grand
chose finalement nous avons piquant
boulons l'applaudissent a été le
meilleur est à venir concourir thil et a
très bien joué surtout peu oui le
montrer lala à bord alors c'est une
lettre qui vient d'une petite fille qui
s'appelle marie laure couderc elle
habite 4 rue voltaire à paris
elle nous a fait un très joli dessin est
très mignonne marie-laure couderc vous
savez ce que l'on pourrait faire
peut-être à chaud croire c'est lui
envoyer un cadeau qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
andrew a pas risquent des quatre amis et
passer can 2000 et ou encore la chanson
des quatre amis on l'envoie à
marie-laure couderc voilà je mets la
lettre de côté je peux dire bonjour un
mari l'a dit bonjour à marie-laure j'ai
dans ma petite marie laure à la barre il
arpentera eh bien tout encore bon
fabrice oui tout de suite à nous
maintenant si tu veux tu vas au tableau
on y va immédiatement
alors tu vas au tableau c'est notre
petit jeu comme d'habitude lui alors tu
as ton harker c'est bien fruits alors je
vais te proposer un mot andy lettre
combien en disent bien comprendre ça ah
oui c'est beaucoup mais et familiale est
alors la première lettre est un pays
oui mais oui alors tu fais huit petits
traits alors une petite raie comme
d'habitude huit petits traits voilà à ça
va être difficile savait difficile oui
oui parce que c'est encore un moyen de
transport métrage et la dernière lettre
ah oui la dernière lettre la dernière
l'aide c'est un e
voilà alors je te disais c'est un moyen
de transport très spécial reste que sur
wii très spécial est un moyen de
transport qui va dans les airs renonce à
bat pas dans les pas du tout je ne crois
pas dans les moyens de transport ti
utilise les rails non non non ça
n'utilise pas drâa sur l'eau est née sur
l'eau non surtout pas sur l'eau ça
serait dangereux que tu que je te donne
sur la route non à son peut aller sur la
route mais il faut faire attention
ah oui il faut faire 13 agents l'autre a
maintenant une autre laisse je vais te
donner la 4e les paris la quatrième
c'est un t1 t comme thérèse comme
thérèse alors un deux trois quatre
voilà alors maintenant tu essaie de
trouver le jeu de dire c'est que les
enfants sont très content avec ce petit
moyen de transport c'est surtout pour
des enfants ses petits-enfants
oui oui la sag est en quelque sorte 1 1
comme un jouet voiture comme un jouet
oui
non moi pas du tout la commune comme un
jouet comme un jouet c'est on peut
monter à plusieurs et donc vaut mieux
être seul vaut mieux être à vomir c'est
un faux message il ya des ronds et il ya
2 euros deux roues ya deux roues deux
petits trous et ça commence par ap il ya
deux roues égales d'euros non faut que
tu m'aides encore je vois pas là
c'est un jouet les enfants devront se
passe souvent à noël ce petit jouet
qu'est-ce que ça que je mette un pied
par terre ils poussent avec un pied ils
ont un pied sur le moyen de transport en
question oui pouces avec l'autre pied
alors maintenant a écrit ça comment mon
pauvre tu as trouvé d'abord et ça
devrait être une patine et puis on
patinait pas voulu malheur ça s'écrit
comme en patinette un ppa deux pays n 1
de terrains bâtis net.com cinq pattes il
est bon mais forcément si tu me mets le
thé là comment veux tu que je trouve
faux-pas dînette commence à ses clients
la la la la bâtie c'est pas normal ça
taquiner maintenait tout voilà une
patinette on pousse bien avec ses pattes
oui mais enfin bon c'est pas avec ses
passes avec son pied si tu veux mais le
thé là je ne peux pas trouver personne
ne trouvera alors je ne peux plus te
dire grand-cho sont aux mains des
talibans
on va y retrouver belles belles à voir
si l'humour est à rubelles belgique
[Musique]
la musique
mlb tu as une belle guitare aujourd'hui
je suis surpris oui tu joue de la
guitare est mieux bien s'y trompe pas
depuis peu de temps mais je commence les
acides oui à l'essai ont fait naître
fait tissu musical si tu veux donc tu
complète par des notes de musique
certains mots de la petite histoire que
je vais te raconter en a qui en fait est
une chanson alors toutes les notes que
tueur a placé la remplaceront les mots
ou plutôt les syllabes que je ne te
dirai pas d'accord bon alors aujourd'hui
c'était une très jolie chanson que
j'étais prépare au que tu m'a préparé
divers cercles par une belle matinée de
printemps alors qu'il fait un beau
soleil
selon lui cette bergère donc et dans sa
ferme entourée de ses chats de ses pains
de ces sommes pas que c'est sympa de
ckoi lapin lapin lapin la prise de
chercher mais alors sur toi qu'elle
fabrique des fromages avec le lait de
ses moutons ou plus exactement de ses
brebis et le chat qui était
tranquillement à rodez belle assise il
voit le fromage des proches ils veulent
goûter et d'un geste m'a droit maladroit
bien oui il fait tomber le fromage par
terre il espère que sa maîtresse ne l'a
pas fait il reste l'on suit si l'on suit
un petit air triste tu as le temps il de
mettre les notes doivent relever alors
les pointeurs triste montables hélas la
lamentable vous vous lamentez lots il se
dit ce n'est pas de sa faute
le fromage qui posé sur un tabouret qui
n'était pas très évident sol id sol puis
plus d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il est
interdit à un chat de manger du fromage
à il n'y a pas de pub le mot de
règlement et voilà non malina nous
sommes d'accord
quiconque voit la ré sol la si la cie la
sole et puis ré ré 6 à eybens et qui
s'échangent et ben écoute ça devrait
donner à peu près comme ça y est
[Musique]
il ya tant d'années
oui mon mec qui passe sans appel quelle
chanceuse et ils étaient tous vers je
revis héros n'est pas le fait d'un tig
avc ou non mais je connais pas très bien
cette chanson non trop les enfants
connaissent par coeur les votes tu n'as
pas de culture musicale à 6 mais c'est
une chanson je connais moins bien
claudio tout quand est-ce que tu
cultives à l'époque déjà cariparma vous
nous y sommes et c'est une bonne
nouvelle tout comme caen vient fabrice
avec nous pour voir le rejoindre la
france soit il tente pas j'ai mon petit
chéri beau diable et à sa famille l'état
la vie et les histoires et les shops et
des chances mais comme juni pas de
baignoire mais bon cap
attention les gars ça me surpasser sont
réunis mais y'a qu'ça ni sont heureux
car ils aiment amis
mais
ces défis
[Musique]
les gagner ça me sont heureux car ils
veulent voir la vie légal c'est mais je
vais pas devenir sa fille de vouloir
devenir amis
mameri oui je trouve que tu n'as pas si
sûr je chante et ça va sans doute mais
pas tous
[Musique]